grazie davvero grazie per l'invito
spero che partano le slide suppongo di
sì
sennò troveremo una soluzione
alternativa
ditemi di si ok perfetto eccomi qua sono
per ora tre lei ma forse ne vedremo
anche delle altre le lady cui andiamo a
parlare oggi tra l'altro parlare dopo
cotanto intervento permettetemi un po di
imbarazzo e sono informatica come avete
sentito un mondo diverso ovviamente dal
suo anche se poi vedrete che ci sono
delle delle belle correlazioni queste
sono le tematiche
lo ha detto professore eccola la sembra
che se ci fossimo messi d'accordo non
saremmo riusciti a fare altrettanta
sintonia nelle definizioni in alcune
cose che vedrete ancora fino alla fine
questa l'intuizione appunto guardare
dentro la definizione prendetela e
adattate la alla vostra vita come volete
voi
l'intuizione però non può e non è
soltanto come vogliamo dire poesia
creatività ma è anche un modo un
approccio alla vita un modo con cui noi
vogliamo fare lavorare la nostra mente
in cui possiamo far lavorare la nostra
mente la nostra mente non funziona come
un computer ripeto sono informatiche
computer funzionano per tassonomie per
algoritmi in maniera molto schematica e
rigorosa
a no perché sennò non sarebbe intuitiva
questa è la vera grossissima differenza
almeno per ora ma poi vedremo
la nostra mente funziona per mappe
mentali per tag cioè per per
concetti dico giallo a lui viene in
mente il sole ea lei viene in mente lo
zafferano
sono due cose diverse sempre giallo è un
computer eseguirebbe l'ordine dopo
giallo devi dirmi sole e quindi sarebbe
per algoritmi noi abbiamo l'intuizione
che ci garantisce per fortuna anche la
creatività la creatività che lo sapete
il brainstorming ve lo insegnano come
funziona deve essere per generare
conoscenza nuove idee e intuizioni di
avere un focus non va interrotto il
flusso dei pensieri non bisogna
giudicare non bisogna interpretare in
maniera che appunto un fiammifero di a
lucia tutti gli altri agenda tutti gli
altri di conseguenza per garantire che
si esca verso la creatività
l'invenzione invece abbiamo dato alla
definizione di intuizione l'invenzione è
invece è in venire quindi trovare e o
sono informati che hanno fatto il
classico e devo dire ne vado fiera
perché mi ha dato alcune basi che
altrimenti non avrei non soltanto quelle
latine ma anzi forse quelle greche un po
di più cercare il punto di raggiungere
una meta intuire e inventare queste poi
vedremo se c'è un legame invenzione che
cos'è e creatività è quella che adesso
si chiama serendipity ovvero mi è
successo qualcosa l'ho trovato è
successo per caso
marconi sapete radio radio lui ha fatto
il primo esperimento dagli stati uniti
verso l'europa
quelle stata serendipity un po di
intuizione ma soprattutto serendipity
perché lui non sapeva l'esistenza della
ionosfera che gli avrebbe fatto
rimbalzare il segnale perché la terra
come sapete non è piatta e quindi non
avrebbe potuto andare dritto c'è la
curvatura terrestre gli avrebbe impedito
a segnare
la ionosfera gliel'ha fatto ti ha fatto
proprio da specchio gliela rimbalzata
giu
serendipity ha avuto l'invenzione idem
colombo colombo andava in india e ha
scoperto l'america è serendipity poi c'è
l'innovazione la terza e di cui vi
parlavo innovare significa fare qualcosa
di nuovo si capisce bene dall etimologia
novo la parola nuovo su un painter mi
dispiace dirlo dopo il professore l'ha
detto sì un pet e sicuramente lo dice
meglio di me e quindi citato così come
lui dice parla della definisce il
concetto di innovazione come la
produzione di qualcosa nuovo ovviamente
non ancora familiare oppure il nuovo
metodo di produzione non ancora
sperimentato un apertura di un nuovo
mercato la conquista di una nuova fonte
di approvvigionamento è stata
un'innovazione l'energia solare o
quant'altro attenzione di attuazione di
una nuova organizzazione industriale e
altro
innovazione mi piace poter cercare di
capire come la parola innovare può
essere declinato anche con l'azione con
il fare qualcosa senza scuse lo diceva
lo diceva lui prima su l'idea di non
rinunciate si è quindi però tenendo
conto che per essere un innovazione vera
deve essere semplice deve essere
sostenibile deve essere sicura di
sicurezza parleranno anche altri credo
consapevole competitiva e inclusiva
perché se esclude qualcuno non innova
allora non possiamo essere sostituiti
almeno non ancora ho messo tra parentesi
non lo so per ora le macchine non
sostituiscono ancora la nostra capacità
di infezione la nostra creatività e
macchine eseguono anche se si parla
ovviamente di intelligenza artificiale
di imparare ma non siamo ancora all'idea
dell'ing
l'intuizione ce l'abbiamo noi
l'intuizione che genera un innovazione e
di conseguenza
un'invenzione per esempio questo lo
diceva einstein la mente come un
paracadute funziona solo se si apre e
questo può appunto trovare lo spazio in
cui decidiamo di tenere la nostra mente
aperta per l'intuizione questa secondo
me non è nell'intuizione né invenzione è
un'idea può essere divertente ma non non
è davvero il concetto di invenzione che
io ho in mente questa forse sì guardate
la foto è una foto nella foto reale di
un paracadute sembra una cosa più o meno
normale lo è oggi siamo abituati a
vedere i paracadute la formula che ha
garantito la possibilità di fare sì che
i paracaduti servono a fare quello che
fanno e guardate qua il primo progetto
di quel paracadute viri faccio vedere
guardate la foto guardate il disegnino
di questo signore leonardo da vinci 1485
ha fatto questo disegno del primo
paracadute poi la storia piano piano è
arrivata dalla sua intuizione perché
quella allora era solo un intuizione è
arrivata all'innovazione perché
finalmente il primo lancio d'aereo col
paracadute cinquecento anni dopo
quattrocento e rotti è stato fatto
questa invece un'intuizione
contrariamente a quelle di colombo e di
marconi che dicevo prima che gli saranno
cadute 100 cose prima di scoprire questa
cosa a tutti noi tutti i giorni casca
qualcosa sicuramente quindi anche a
newton a suo tempo però è stata quella
mela quel giorno in quel contesto che
gli ha permesso di inventare di di
inventare di definire appunto di quello
che diceva il professore prima di
arrivare a una conclusione che era
nell'aria perché le mele sono sempre
cascate ma che ha avuto in quell'istante
l'intuizione di poter dire e adesso
faccio innovazione perché adesso
definisco la formula della gravità
vedete un po voi
c'è una quarta è anche questo sembra
incredibile ma veramente mi parlava al
professore prima non sono solo queste
l'istruzione siamo tra l'altro in uno
dei templi dell'istruzione ben felici di
esserci ci sono i problemi che dicevamo
prima però questa è la cosa che a me
personalmente intristisce di più in
assoluto come si fa a chiedere a dei
bambini di 6 anni 6 qualche volta anche
di stare una mattina intera seduti
dietro un banco ad ascoltare un genio
voglio dire per carità ma è un bambino
un bambino è veramente una forzatura che
gli censura la creatività che lo blocca
nella nell'istinto e quindi di
conseguenza nell'intuizione non è così
come non è devo dire questo palco è
fatto così perché 3 dec funziona così
ma non è così che si interessino a me
personalmente quando insegno
all'università
sto in mezzo li vedo gli studenti sono
imbarazzatissimi dalla mia presenza
anche ma è l'unico modo se vogliamo
interagire dobbiamo interagire tra pari
inginocchiandosi sedendoci eventual
mente quando provate a parlare come un
bambino
ci sono due modi di approcciare un
bambino un bambino si può guardare così
gli si parla così questo povero bambino
si guarda così non è il modo giusto
mi piego e mi metto occhi occhi da pari
in quel modo cresciamo entrambi intuiamo
e troviamo soluzioni entrambe queste
sono frasi nomi e ma rendono bene l'idea
è quindi perché inventarne di nuove
quando qualcuno la vetta è meglio di me
prima ivan illich el'istruzione forzosa
spegne nella maggioranza delle persone
la voglia di imparare ed è proprio il
modo di fare scuola che dobbiamo provare
a rivoluzionare e mark twain che dice ho
fatto modo che la scuola non
interferisco la mia istruzione
istruzione
ovviamente viene dalla scuola ci
mancherebbe altro ma non solo ed eccolo
là la città lui prima se l'avessimo
fatta apposta non ci saremo riusciti
lui ha letto il bando
ma ricordatevi come va avanti il film
salgono i ragazzi sul banco quindi c'è
un ulteriore non è più l'ex cattedra no
quindi il professore che da dal palco
dalla cattedra elargisce le sue
conoscenze ma li tira su per dire siamo
insieme lottiamo e collaboriamo insieme
se non si fa squadra se non si lavora
insieme tra chi insegna chi impara non
si arriva da nessuna parte in questo
senso veramente c'è da lavorare lì
creatività che viene lasciata libera e
intuizione e gandhi l'ultima citazione
l'istruzione senza il coraggio e come
una statua di cera bella a vedersi ma
destinata a sciogliersi con sostanza
calda quindi ci vuole anche il taglio di
cambiare anche ammettendo che abbiamo
avuto l'intuizione di salire sulla
cattedra di tirare dentro i ragazzi
rischiamo di restare così se non andiamo
avanti e lasciamo che il coraggio se ne
vada per la sua strada non ci piace
quindi futuro progresso sicuramente
declinandole con l'istruzione rivista
nel modo in cui dicevo ma come diceva
james bond 33 33 33 lui diceva realtà
dove sono le cose ma intuizione
invenzione e innovazione devono lavorare
e andare avanti insieme
qui sono i miei riferimenti dove mi
trovate su twitter via mail o linkedin o
comunque nei social mi trovate ovunque
aggiungo un'altra piccola cosa visto che
c'è ancora sei minuti un matematico
fisico teologo filosofo disse blaise
pascal giri in grado di dispiace nelle
sue famose lettere mi dispiace di non
essere stato capace di mandare una
lettera breve lo scritto a troppo lunga
perché non ho avuto tempo di preparare
la più breve
ricordatevi che per fare questo
quando si fanno speech ed è questo
bisogna prepararsi perché solo la
preparazione ci consente di essere
sintetici
grazie